hello friends we're here at e3 and guess
who i ran into oh my goodness
oh your camera is so cute it's a little
square i never even saw that before
that's awesome we're about to head into
uh a nintendo wii u little exclusive
event here
the big blue tent
right now i is i was hoping he would
talk to me but i can't see your name
today oh no do you see my name
okay
oh reggie
ah
me
the opening of e3 somehow we managed to
get in
hello how are you
so we finally meet this is this is
amazing i'm so excited we're finally
meeting it's awesome i don't think i saw
that for free plain tweet until somebody
retweeted it that was like a year later
it was a haiku it's like a loving come
sit in the middle seat next to me
not creepy
baby
what are you guys looking forward to at
e3 today
square
and behind me is the new xbox one and
the new xbox 360 which is essentially
the same as the old 360 but they made it
a slim down for you and that's actually
the version that we're going to be
giving you guys you can go to awel's
facebook page i'll put all the links in
the description and you can have a
chance to win
when i just gotten somebody's shot so
i'm gonna i'm gonna
hello
we were just discussing xbox first
playstation man it's getting brutal it
is getting worse yeah i might go
playstation though this is good you can
get a playstation i'll get the xbox and
then we can just spin yeah it's great
it'll be a custody battle what do you
want this weekend do you want the xbox
you have a place
here
oh
right here is the activation call of
duty they have
a bunch of calls
we have received a potential threat from
dhs headquarters there has been a breach
onboard the oath space station send
warning
so right now we're at the e3 machinima
party no
it hasn't actually started yet but the
coolest thing ever is it is sponsored by
cinnamon toast
crunch
i kid you not
more
cinnamon toast oh my god wait is the
cinnamon toast oh chapstick i am taking
this right this second there's so much
sandwiches crunch i mean this may be the
best day ever and let me just show you
how pretty
it's done it looks
what are you doing over there i need you
to say hi to my friends again they've
missed you hey what's going on oh it's
backlit i'm gonna need you to move this
way tell me who are the djs tonight oh
my goodness we have two very amazing djs
tonight we have tritonal and we have
cruella richiel
cosplay cinnamon toast crunch
djs machinima you guys did a freaking
fantastic job with this party that
hasn't even started yet but look at this
this is
you